in today's video we're trying to survive
the most extreme experiments ever
everything from a nuclear meltdown to a
giant volcano to a tunnel made of tnt
and for this first challenge the boys
have to survive a massive nuclear
meltdown and make it to the boat before
they die if you don't survive you have
to bungee jump off a bridge what no
begin the meltdown
i'm out wait are we sure this is the
right way carl no and we gotta make it
to the boat
i i can't see i just got blasphemed oh
i'm stuck in a hole there's radiation
falling from the sky oh dear god
oh it landed on
me zombies i'm stuck in a hole jimmy i
got screwed over i can't move
i'm dead chris now has the bungee jump
where is the boat does anybody want to
let me know where the boat is ow that's
nice
i'm taking so much damage right now
who's gonna bungee jump with chris
no
i died two down
where's the boat riddle i'm at the boat
rental place oh my god i see it yeah i
see it i'm about to make it to the boat
taylor's about to make it
i made it
no bungee jumping for me baby
i'm on a boat congratulations chandler
carl you don't have to jump off a bridge
i'm so scared
screw minecraft voice do you see that
giant dam behind you yes it's holding
back a literal ocean and it's about to
break if you die you have to wear 10
layers of merch in the next challenge
make it to the high ground
oh look at the water squirting out ew
all right it's coming
oh
i'm following carl punch me forward i'm
trying oh you're too fast slow down oh
let's catch it up it's catching up
ladder go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go
oh they make it will they make it i
can't see
water
yeah
we're live almost all of us did it
that's hot that's not how this works
stolen gotta put on 10 layers of merch
they punched me off all right throw this
on
[Music]
now the hoodies
last one
and now he has 10 pieces of merch on are
you hot i'm hotter than carl's mom
this next round the boys have to race
through an insane obstacle course and if
you win you get five thousand dollars
all right let's go
whoa this map has cheez-its and pringles
we do have that because they're the
sponsor of the video they're watching
the build for better contest in
minecraft you can build a playground at
minecraft take a photo and submit it the
winning design will be used as
inspiration to build a real playground
in real life bro i'm so far behind how
are you moving so fast jesus and
pringles has also launched a promotion
where you can get free mind coins that's
a lot of cheddar like cheez-its no joke
they have these creeper rice krispies
treats oh man minecraft cheez-its even
minecraft pringles they taste really
good all you have to do is purchase one
of the participating products and you'll
get 350 minecoins for minecraft i'm so
far at nola where are you i'm still on
the pigs head to kfr.com minecraft or
click the description to submit your
build to your playground and redeem your
minecoins jimmy you ate me i lost
congratulations chris i'm winning five
grand next bit this huge tunnel is made
entirely out of tnt and if you can make
it out alive you win if you don't
survive you have to eat a soggy hot dog
eww no shot and before you go i just
want to let you guys know that you have
one skip during this video start the tnt
oh the tnt is exploding oh it's just
stuff it doesn't look like this is
survivable
i just fell through i'm pretty sure
nolan's dead oh it's behind me
getting a louder i'm going to skip this
one you don't want to eat a soggy hot
dog
no i think i'm going to skip this one
chandler's using his skip come on i'm
doing it come on oh my gosh chris you're
on the edge
oh that's not fair
yes
yes
i'm so awesome gentlemen i'm preparing
two soggy hot dogs grab this hot dog all
the way all the way it's cold
it's really not that bad that's the
grossest thing i've ever had
you are now trapped in a room see that
arrow
every time it hits something it
multiplies oh
if you die you have to put a banana peel
on your head only one of you is going to
live
there's nowhere to hide
i just saw nolan get murdered
there's a button over top of me maybe
the button will save me i'm gonna hit
people behind corners like what's this
i'm actually not hiding in a corner i'm
figurating i'm doing this i forgot he
was
ah i got it
everyone moved to a different part of
the map you guys are all being wusses i
have two hearts left what do you mean
oh no
chandler's getting a banana remember
whoever's last remaining doesn't have
the banana head i'm gonna run through
the middle i'm
invincible do you nolan i died carl how
many hearts do you have i have one heart
left
i'm tired of carl winning chris win this
for the boys carl keep it moving i'm
moving i will keep moving
okay whoa
hey i didn't suck this time guys you
didn't suck at minecraft here you go
there's your banana peel oh my god all
right there's his banana i'm good to
game
there you go next bit the next
experiment is if a gas lab leak toxic
gas and you try to survive this time i'm
competing
you guys tell when to start and tell me
what my punishment is start
jimmy is literally right behind you bro
wait what's my punishment you have to
put a hot dog in a banana peel and take
a bite and you have to do it at walmart
in public all right you know i'm not
gonna die jimmy you're so dead
jimmy you know it sucked if it just
started snowing oh god it's snowing oh i
hate you oh it's not oh wait no he's
sinking yeah that's powdered snow you
fall through it bro this isn't even a
challenge that wasn't me go jimmy joe
no
chris played a bunch of snow and then i
got stuck you're just falling in the
snow that's not us hey guys future jimmy
here i've been really busy because we're
recreating willy wonka's chocolate
factory in real life so i'll do this
punishment in the future when i have
more time enjoy the video for this next
challenge you have to use your skip
before i reveal the punishment do any of
you want to skip it yes since you're
skipping you don't even have to compete
what you guys have to survive to
spreading of a dangerous mutant virus
the punishment for dying in this
challenge is you have to take a bath and
hot dog water
begin oh
oh god i'm already catching it go carl
go you're behind me punch me if you're
behind me punch me go trailer thank you
guys have you ever wondered what's a
passing hot dog water like why would you
punch me jimmy
stop the hot dog water please
i'll see you at the bathtub
oh it's so fast i'm still alive i'm
still alive
oh no hot dark water
carl's still alive carl's gonna make it
yes
yes
carl survived
i'm so good and guys i also made it so
yeah hey chris you made it to the
bathtub see you there i hate everyone
this next experiment is to see if you
can escape this giant erupting volcano
and make it to the escape boat if you're
gonna skip you gotta do it before i tell
you the punishment we only have three
challenges left so be careful we're not
using our skips jim jam if you die in
this challenge you have to show us the
last thing you googled my mom watches
these godspeed gentlemen
oh there's lightning too go go trailer
we got to protect our internet browsing
history oh god i can't lose this one
oh look at the
volcano oh it's rumblings
i'm doing this for my browsing history
wait what
what there's a giant hole in front of me
i made the bridge it made the bridge
wait did i go too fast oh carl you got
her oh
that is so messed up
my god i'm taking so much damage i'm at
the dock i'm at the dock oh good
traveler parkour
no no no no no no i'm at the duck i'm
gonna live
oh
chris
why this blue
come on come on come on oh yeah
yeah
chris the volcano's coming get out of
here
ah what the freak why did i jump chris
fell what an idiot no
nolan you just got crashed uh go chris
i did it
i'm gonna do it this time yes i live
looks like carlos the only church
history we're checking creator of kids
next door
okay and now that we saw what you
searched remember how you guys both had
skips that was the last challenge thanks
for watching goodbye